how's it going everybody it's Warren
welcome back to the channel ever since
Christian Bale was announced to be in
talks with Marvel Studios about playing
a role in Thor love and thunder the
Internet has been freaking out trying to
figure out just who is he going to play
now it was pretty obvious who the fans
wanted him to play as the night that
that report was announced beta ray bill
started trending well as it turns out we
may be getting what we want in a number
of different ways we have a recent
report that confirms character details
about Christian Bale's upcoming
character in Thor at love and thunder
and not only does this report confirm
that he could in fact be playing beta
ray bill but it also suggests that
Christian Bale could be playing
Adam warlock or the Silver Surfer so
I'll breakdown this report on the
details of Christian Bale's upcoming
character in for love and thunder as
well as talk about the chances of him
possibly playing Adam warlock or the
Silver Surfer and how it makes perfect
sense for them to debut and Thor love
and thunder if you're new be sure to
subscribe to stay up to date on all the
latest MCU news and so you can enter my
giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox one
or ps4 today's report comes from the
Illuminati dot-com they've got a lot of
credit recently as they've been leaking
many things relating to the Marvel
Cinematic Universe and other franchises
as well and last night they reported
that Christian Bale has in fact accepted
a role of a particular character in Thor
love and thunder and they are signing
the paperwork right now although they
stated that the paperwork is not yet
complete and although they weren't able
to confirm the character that he's going
to be playing they were able to provide
some details about this character
according to the Illuminati they say
that they have received concrete
confirmation that the actor Christian
Bale will be playing an intergalactic
villain and Thor love and thunder they
got a glimpse at a Marvel Studios
document that gave away some tidbits of
information about the negotiations of
Christian Bale to play the lead in Thor
love and thunder and according to what
they saw this so-called lead role is
going to be for the main villain of the
film a villain that is confirmed to be
an alien species who was described as
being other-worldly now everybody pretty
much speculated that Christian Bale
would be playing the villain of the
movie even if that villain was to be
beta ray bill because after all in the
comics when Thor and beta ray bill first
met they had a fight to the death and
although this information
doesn't confirm who Christian Bale is
going to be playing given the
information that we've received and
given the information that we know about
Christian Bale we can pretty much narrow
it down to five characters he could
possibly be playing in Thor love and
thunder the first character is as I
mentioned and as everybody wants it to
be is beta ray bill beta ray bill and
Thor have a long history together in the
comics now you may know beta ray bill as
a very good friend of Thor which he does
eventually become but when they first
meet they're not so much friends and
beta ray bill is definitely a threat in
fact it's actually revealed that beta
ray bill is worthy enough to lift mule
near the two of them eventually end up
back on Asgard and a beta ray bill wants
to keep mule near for himself Odin sends
beta ray bill and Thor away to fight to
the death to see who gets to claim you
near now it's a pretty close fight but
beta ray bill would ultimately go on to
win as Thor gets knocked out unconscious
and is about to die but beta ray bill
saves him beta ray bill then takes Thor
back to Asgard and Odin actually grants
beta ray bill Stormbreaker he actually
forges it for him not like what we saw
in Avengers in game Thor love and
thunder could go on to adapt the first
meeting between Thor and beta ray bill
when they were enemies after all we
already know that Jane Foster is going
to be able to lift a mule near and that
she's going to become lady Thor
well beta ray bill and the comics also
becomes a different version of Thor he
himself being worthy enough to lift a
mule near and Stormbreaker so it's
possible that we could see multiple
hammer and axe wielding characters in
Thor love and thunder if Christian Bale
does indeed play beta ray bill but then
there's somebody who's been rumored to
be the villain of Thor love and thunder
for quite some time now so coming in at
number two is gore the god butcher gore
grew up on a nameless barren planet and
when his mother mate and children died
he thought that gods could not exist
because they would help him and because
of this thinking he was exiled and out
casted by his tribe when he eventually
did learn that gods did in fact exist
but didn't help those in need such as
his dying family he vowed to kill them
all hence his name gore at the god
butcher and then to make matters worse
he acquired the all-black necro sword he
acquired the Gaul black neck restored
from Knoll after watching him fight a
golden God and realizing that there is a
way to kill gods gore eventually goes to
earth finds Thor and he almost kills him
but Thor gets reinforcements gore
escapes but
has his arm cut off and he realizes that
he's going to need help if he's going to
kill gods so he creates an army of
shadow berserkers and he starts to kill
gods one by one Thor eventually notices
that the gods are going missing and goes
to investigate and after a very intense
battle one that involves time travel he
eventually kills Gore the all-black neck
ressort is banished but fun fact Thor
would later go on in the comics to use
the sword to battle Galactus it would
certainly be very interesting to see
gore the god butcher info 11 Thunder
however his character is kind of similar
to hella anti Kuwaiti even did say that
he drew influence from Gore the god
butcher for hella and her powers so even
though Gore is definitely a possibility
we probably won't see Gore as we saw
hella in Thor Ragnarok and they're kind
of similar but of course there still are
other characters and coming in at number
three is mephesto to be honest mephesto
should have made his MCU debut a long
time ago Mephisto is a character that
has existed for over four decades in the
Marvel Comics universe and he actually
ties quite well into Thor 11 thunder and
into Phase four mephesto is actually a
classic villain of Thor appearing in
Thor number 180 through 181 astonishing
tales number eight and Thor number 204
through 205 and this report talks about
otherworldly characters and mephesto is
actually from a different realm so it
could be mephesto that they are talking
about and not to mention he has some
ties into the one division series and to
Doctor Doom Cynthia von doom is
reportedly going to appear in the one
division series and we have further
evidence of this as we've seen some
leaked photos for the one division
series that show witches and not to
mention it's been reported that the one
division series is going to visit
Latveria which is where Cynthia Von Doom
is from at one point in time in the
comics Cynthia uses magic to summon
mephesto she makes a deal with him for
the power to free her people and keep
them safe she would end up getting
killed not too long after and her soul
went to mephesto realm where he tortured
her Victor Von Doom aka dr. doom would
soon go on to discover that his mother's
soul was with mephesto being tortured
and once he learned magic he summoned
him and offered to duel him for the
chance to bring his mother's soul back
Mephisto agreed but dr. doom could never
defeat him now it's been rumoured that
dr. doom is going to make an appearance
in
Black Panther 2 and in ant-man 3 the
fact that Doctor Doom is going to appear
and the fact that Cynthia Von Doom is
said to be in Wanda vision and the fact
that mephesto is a classic Thor villain
and should have been introduced in the
MCU a while ago means that there is a
very high chance that mephesto could be
the character that Christian Bale is
going to play but of course there are
two other major characters that
everybody would love Christian Bale to
play and number four is Adam warlock now
in the comics Adam warlock or him was
first created on earth after rebelling
against his creators the first person
that he comes in contact with and in
conflict with is Thor eventually causing
Adam warlock to leave Earth now Adam
warlock is set up a little bit
differently in the MCU as we saw in the
post-credits scene of guardians of the
galaxy volume 2 in the MCU Adam warlock
will be created by the sovereign and he
will be created for the sole purpose of
destroying the guardians of the galaxy
meaning when we see Adam for the very
first time in the MCU he's going to be
evil which would mean he could be the
main villain of Thor love and thunder
and not to mention right now for is
technically with the guardians of the
galaxy when we left him at the end of
Avengers endgame he left with the
Guardians and wherever Thor's going the
Guardians going to take him there so if
Adam warlock is going to track down the
guardians it could very well mean that
he's going to make his MCU debut in Thor
love and thunder Adam warlock was one of
the most powerful characters ever
created in the Marvel Comics universe
and a fan favorite and since the MCU and
guardians of the galaxy vol 2 has
already set up out of Morlock to appear
and since he's had run-ins with Thor in
the comics and not to mention that Thor
is currently with the guardians of the
galaxy Adam warlock is a perfect
candidate for Christian Bale to be plain
and for love and thunder and the last
but not least a character that we would
all love for Christian Bale to play and
Thor 11 Thunder is the Silver Surfer
we know that Galactus is coming there
have been numerous reports stating that
Galactus is the next fan oohs and
honestly it just makes sense if you want
to outdo Thanos which Marvel has to do
you bring in Galactus and now that
Marvel finally has the rights to be able
to use him in the MCU along with the
Silver Surfer it's only a matter of time
until he enters the MCU but not before
his Herald the Silver Surfer enters the
MCU and when the Silver Surfer first
appears he is most likely
going to be the villain of course he's
going to be the Herald of Galactus he's
going to be searching for worlds for
Galactus to eat and we know that the
Silver Surfer is eventually going to
come to earth and we know that Thor is
eventually going to go back to earth and
for love and thunder because that's
where Jane Foster is and perhaps that's
even why he recruits Jane Foster to be
another version of Thor to help him
fight the Silver Surfer Thor is over
1,500 years old he's been all throughout
the galaxy and he's been to many
different realms there's no doubt that
he's heard of Galactus and there's no
doubt that he knows that Galactus has
heralds so Thor an Avenger and protector
of Earth and former king of Asgard which
currently resides in Earth would
obviously want to fight and stop the
Silver Surfer from going back to
Galactus to bring to earth not to
mention it has been rumored not
confirmed but rumored that the Silver
Surfer is going to be making an
appearance in for love and thunder there
have been talks that Keanu Reeves could
play the Silver Surfer and Thor love and
thunder but now that Christian Bale is
almost officially signed on he could be
the one that has taken on that role so
out of these five who would you like to
see Christian Bale play and for love and
thunder or do you think that it's a
completely different character
altogether let me know what you think in
the comments down below don't forget to
give this video like and subscribe and
notifications turned on to stay up to
date on everything relating to the MCU
and so you can enter my giveaway for a
chance to win an Xbox one or a ps4 I'm
picking a winner at five hundred and
fifty thousand subscribers as always
thank you all so much for watching
woof woof